Razors phone isn't a gaming phone per se
but it is a device built for gamers as a
result it breaks unprecedented ground in
a few areas but falters and others I'm
here to walk you through the top five
things you should know about the razor
phone the razor phone uses a 5.7 inch
2560 by 1440 P display this is the same
resolution that many high-end gaming
monitors use and it looks really sharp
what really makes it unique though is
the fact that it features a variable
refresh rate that's similar to gsync or
freesync and it can scale up to 120
Hertz most other phones are locked to 60
it may be hard to tell from this video
but this makes game play and even basic
scrolling look super silky smooth really
have to see it in motion to know what
I'm talking about it's really refreshing
to see razor break into a mature market
here and disrupt a bunch of leading
phone manufacturers like Apple Google
and Samsung one downside here is that it
doesn't use an OLED panel like many
other flagships and obsolete an IPS LCD
instead this means that it doesn't
feature true black levels that OLED
displays offer which might be a
deal-breaker to some but unfortunately
they don't make 120 Hertz OLED panels in
terms of specs the razor phone uses
top-tier Android parts it's equipped
with Qualcomm's leading Snapdragon 835
SOC coupled with a massive 8 gigabytes
of RAM to put things into perspective
that's twice as much RAM as Google's
flagship pixel 2 XL it also has a huge
4000 milliamp hour battery that is more
than capable of lasting a typical day
all it comes with 64 gigabytes of
built-in storage it thankfully allows
you to install a microSD card so you can
expand it up to 2 terabytes why can't
other flagship phones do the same the
razor phone has an 8 megapixel f/2
front-facing camera coupled with 2
cameras on the back one is a 12
megapixel wide-angle and there's another
12 megapixel zoom the bad news is that
the cameras are pretty bad
overall they make images look much too
soft and lack image clarity in addition
the back cameras oddly shoot almost
everything in a forced portrait mode so
that only a certain part of the image
will be in focus its confusingly bad
software updates could potentially
address some of these issues
but if you're looking for a great camera
on your phone I'd focus elsewhere from
now the razor phone has two large bezels
at the top and bottom but I don't really
mind them because the company is
squeezed in some amazing speakers here
as a matter of fact I'd say they are the
best phone speakers currently on the
market they're good enough to replace
small cheap Bluetooth equivalents the
razor phone is rocking Android nougat
7.1.1 with the clean Nova Launcher skin
it also comes with different Razer
themes you can download along with
additional settings allow you to
optimize battery life over performance
and vice versa razer tells me it plans
to update the phone to android 8.0 oreo
in q1 next year but it hasn't laid out
an update roadmap beyond it so that was
five things you should know about the
razer phone does it pique your interest
let us know thanks for watching